(dramatic music)
>> AUGUST 30TH.
TODAY IS NOVEMBER 11TH.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT DOESN’T KNOW HOW MANY
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
STILL LEFT?
IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> WE DON’T HAVE A NUMBER FOR
YOU WE BELIEVE IT’S CERTAINLY,
A, -- MOST LIKELY IN THE DOZENS,
ONE OF THE REASONS WE PUT THE
MEMO OUT LAST WEEK WAS TO
ENCOURAGE SERVICE MEMBERS TO
COME FORWARD.
BRIAN: EMBARRASSING.
THE PENTAGON TAKING HEAT AND
THEY SHOULD OVER ITS EFFORTS TO
RESCUE FAMILY MEMBERS OR LACK
THEREOF OF AMERICAN TROOPS STILL
STRANDED IN AFGHANISTAN AND OUR
ALLIES.
OUR NEXT GUEST SERVED ON THE
FRONT LINES OF THE WAR ON TERROR
AS MEMBERS OF THE ELITE NAVY
SEAL TEAMS AND NOW RUNNING FOR
CONGRESS.
RETIRED NAVY SEAL SNIPER DAVID
BROOK.
RETIRED NAVY SEAL CHIEF DERRICK
VAN ORDEN WANTS TO REPRESENT
WISCONSIN’S THIRD DISTRICT.
ALMOST GOT IT LAST TIME.
HE WANTS IT THIS TIME.
ELON CRANE JOINS THE NAVY DAYS
AFTER 9/11 AND RUNNING IN
OREGON’S FIRST DISTRICT VERY
SUCCESSFUL BUSINESSMAN AND MARK
LUTTRELL IS AIMING TO REPRESENT
TEXAS’ 18TH.
RETIRED NAVY SEAL AND FORMER
INTERIOR SECRETARY RYAN ZINKE
RUNNING FOR MONTANA’S BRAND NEW
SECOND DISTRICT.
THEY JOIN US NOW TO REACT.
FIRST OFF CONGRESSMAN ZINKE, I’M
GOING TO START WITH YOU.
HOW WAS THAT ACCEPTABLE THAT
ADMIRABLE KIRBY A SPOKESPERSON
FOR THE -- ADMIRAL KIRBY
COULDN’T TELL US WHO WAS LEFT
BEHIND AND DOESN’T A SEEM THAT
INTERESTED.
>> YOUR POINT IS EXCELLENT.
WHERE IS THE CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION?
THIS IS A BIDEN-CREATED CRISIS
THAT WE HAVE LEFT OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE LEFT OUR ALLIES HANGING
IN THE WINDS AND NOT ONLY HAS
OUR GOVERNMENT NOT BEEN HELPFUL
OF GETTING OUR PEOPLE OUT, THEY
HAVE BEEN, IN MANY CASES, THE
OBSTACLES.
I’M CONTACTED EVERY DAY BY
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
INTERPRETERS, FAMILY MEMBERS
THAT NEED TO GET OUT OF THAT
COUNTRY AND, IN MANY CASES, OUR
STATE DEPARTMENT, UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT ONLY BEEN
NOT HELPFUL, THEY ARE THE CHIEF
OBSTACLE OF GETTING OUR PEOPLE
OUT.
WE SHOULD HAVE INVESTIGATIONS
AND GET TO THE TRUTH ABOUT
WHAT’S GOING ON.
BRIAN: HE LIE, YOU DO YOUELI, TH
19 TIMES TO GET THEM OUT.
WHAT THEY SAY IS YOU CAN GO BUT
LEAVE YOUR FAMILY BEHIND.
WHAT PERSON IS GOING TO LEAVE
THEIR FAMILY BEHIND IN THAT
PLACE AND JUST GET ON A PLANE BY
THEMSELVES AND NOW THE
ADMINISTRATION SAID WELL, WE
MADE THEM AN OFFER.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
AND IT’S JUST ONE OF THE --
YEAH, IT’S JUST ONE UNONE OF THE
MANY ISSUES THAT ARE DESTROYING
THIS COUNTRY.
THAT’S WHY WE ALL RECOGNIZE IT
THAT’S WHY YOU HAVE FIVE NAVY
SEALS ON THE SCREEN WHO ARE
RUNNING FOR OFFICE BECAUSE WE
WANT TO SERVE THIS COUNTRY
AGAIN.
WE NEED YOUR HELP.
WE NEED YOU GUYS TO GET ON OUR
WEBSITE.
SUPPORT US.
WE ALSO WANT YOU GUYS TO GO,
BECOME PRECINCT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
WE ALSO WANT YOU TO RUN FOR
SCHOOL BOARD.
IF WE WANT A GOVERNMENT, IT’S
OF, FOR AND BY THE PEOPLE, WE
GOT TO START ACTING LIKE IT.
BRIAN: ENOUGH ABOUT PARTY AND
START THINKING ABOUT THE
COUNTRY.
I WANT YOU TO TAKE THIS IN,
MORGAN.
THIS IS THE PENTAGON
SPOKESPERSON ADMIRAL KIRBY WHO I
KNOW IS A GOOD GUY.
I THINK HE IS SUBJECTED TO BAD
POLICY.
THIS IS WHAT HE ACTUALLY SAID
WHEN IT CAME TO THREATS TO
AMERICA.
>> WHICH IS A BIGGER THREAT, THE
CLIMATE OR CHINA.
>> BOTH ARE EQUALLY IMPORTANT.
BOTH ARE CHALLENGES THAT THE
SECRETARY WANTS, THE SENIOR
LEADERSHIP THE PENTAGON TO BE
FOCUSED ON AS WELL AS MANY
OTHERS, TOO.
BRIAN: MORGAN, WHO SHOULD WOULD
HE BE MORE CONCERNED WITH, THE
PLANET DROPPING ONE DEGREE OR
GOING UP ONE DEGREE OR CHINA’S
NAVY WHICH HAS SURPASSED OURS
AND THE WAY THEY PLOWED OVER
HONG KONG?
THEY ARE LOOKING TO TAKE OVER
CENTRAL AND SOUTH AMERICA
ECONOMICALLY AND WHO KNOWS WHAT
ELSE?
WHAT’S A BIGGER THREAT TO MORGAN
LUTTRELL?
>> OBVIOUSLY CHINA.
THE NAVY IS ONE THING BUT THEIR
CYBERSECURITY THREAT.
PUMPING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO
THEIR CYBER PLATFORMS WHICH WE
ARE NOT LOOKING AT IN MY
OPINION.
I LIKE TO ADD THIS ABOUT THE
AFGHANISTAN ISSUE.
IF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
SO CONCERNED ABOUT SAVING
AMERICAN LIVES WITH THESE MASK
MANDATES AND SO FORTH.
WHY DON’T THEY MANDATE WE RESCUE
OUR CITIZENS AND SAVE THEIR
LIVES AS WELL OVER IN
AFGHANISTAN.
I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO RUN
INTO A INTERPRETER WHO SERVED
WITH US OVERSEAS SO LONG IN THE
PAST COUPLE OF WEEKS.
HIS FAMILY IS STILL OVER THERE.
HE PLEADED WITH US.
HE BEGGED US.
HE IS LIKE WHO DO I NEED TO GET
TO HELP ME GET MY FAMILY OVER.
SPOKE PERFECT ENGLISH.
WHERE IS THAT ALL BIDEN HAS TO
DO IS SAY LET’S DO THIS.
LET’S MANDATE THIS.
TANK MILLEY AND AUSTIN GET OUR
PEOPLE.
IF THEY ARE PUMPING THAT -- BIG
PHARMA THAT IS PUMPING THAT
MONEY INTO THE DNC ALL YOU ARE
HEARING ON THE NEWS IS MANDATES
AND VACCINES.
WHY DON’T WE GET SOME PEOPLE TO
SAY THE SAME THING ABOUT OUR
CITIZENS OVERSEAS AND BRING THEM
HOME.
BRIAN: YEAH.
OR THE ALLIES THAT HELPED YOU
GUYS FOR 20 YEARS.
HEY, BRADY, IF THE PRESIDENT
DOESN’T SAY THAT AND YOU ARE
AUSTIN OR MILLIE, HOW COULD YOU
WEAR THE UNIFORM AND JUST MOVE
ON TO SOMETHING ELSE?
I KNOW IT’S THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, BUT AT WHAT
POINT IS THE BREAKING POINT WHEN
IT COMES TO RED, WHITE, AND BLUE
AND SERVING A PRESIDENT THAT’S
INDIFFERENT TO A WAR HE SAYS HE
LOST FAITH IN?
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, I THINK IT’S
REALLY SAD TO SEE THE LEADERSHIP
AT THIS POINT SEEMING TO BE
CARELESS ABOUT TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT WAS A
BOTCHED WITHDRAWAL.
I THINK WITHDRAWAL IS GOING TOO
FAR.
I THINK IT’S REALLY JUST A
RETREAT.
YOU CAN’T SAY THAT IT’S A
SUCCESSFUL WHEN YOU TURN YOUR
BACK TO THE ENEMY ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
WHILE THERE ARE AMERICANS THAT
WE MUST -- WE MUST RESCUE FROM
THIS COUNTRY.
I THINK WE HAVE TO -- WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS WAS A
FAILURE.
THAT THIS WAS A FAILURE AND WE
CANNOT CONTINUE THIS WAY.
DEEPLY UNAMERICAN.
BRIAN: NOT FAIR TO YOU GUYS.
YOU DESERVE BETTER.
SOMEONE MADE THE FINAL DECISION
WHILE YOU FOUGHT FOR 20 YEARS.
IT’S JUST NOT FAIR.
REAL QUICK, WHAT IS GREAT FOR US
IS THAT YOU ARE HERE ON VETERANS
DAY AND STILL TRYING TO GIVE
BACK ONLY IN A SUIT INSTEAD OF A
UNIFORM.
LET’S GO AROUND, STARTING WITH
YOU CONGRESSMAN ZINKE WHO SERVED
AS SECRETARY OF THE INTERIOR.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS TODAY?
>> YOU KNOW, THE LEVEL OF SOUTH
AFRICA FIGHT THAT HAS BEEN MADE.
PARTICULARLY, YOU KNOW, IF YOU
ARE A VETERAN AND THE FIRST LINE
GUYS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
YOU KNOW, THE DAYS OF
CELEBRATION OF HOW GREAT THE
CHARACTER IS OF OUR VETERANS,
AND OUR MILITARY, WE HAVE
CHALLENGES BUT I THINK YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IT’S RED, WHITE, AND BLUE AND
LET’S TAKES BACK THIS COUNTRY.
BRIAN: ELI CRANE, YOU WANT TO BE
A CONGRESSMAN, YOUR THOUGHTS
TODAY BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE SUFFERING BECAUSE THEY SEE
WHAT HAPPENED IN LATE AUGUST.
AND THEY KNOW THERE IS TWO WEEKS
LEFT IN DECEMBER TO GET PEOPLE
OUT OR THE WINTER GETS TOO
TOUGH.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
VETERANS DAY?
>> ELI?
>> MY THOUGHTS ARE THIS.
FREEDOM IS ALWAYS ONE GENERATION
AWAY FROM EXTENSION.
WE HAVE TO ACT LIKE THAT.
THESE GUYS ARE WILLING TO GO
SERVE.
THE TIME FOR COMPLACENCY IS
OVER.
AND YOU CAN SEE HOW QUICKLY THIS
RADICAL IDEOLOGY CAN DESTROY
THIS COUNTRY IF WE DON’T DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
BRIAN: DERRICK VAN ORDEN?
>> HEY, LISTEN, TODAY IS
VETERANS DAY AS WE SAID I WANT
TO SAY THANKS TO EVERY SINGLE
MAN AND WOMAN WHO HAS SERVED OUR
NATION.
GIVEN US FREEDOM FROM THE
REVOLUTIONARY WAR AND KEPT THIS
NATION FREE.
WE OWE A DEBT OF GRATITUDE TO
OUR VETERANS.
WE HAVE HAD A SPIKE IN VETERAN
SUICIDE 41% OVER Q 2 TO Q 3.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
VETERANS UNDERSTAND THAT WE LOVE
AND CARE FOR THEM AND THAT THE
DUTY NEVER ENDS.
ANOTHER THING TODAY THAT PEOPLE
DON’T THINK ABOUT, ALL THE GOLD
STAR FAMILIES WHO LOST MEN AND
WOMEN SERVING OUR COUNTRY
DESERVE OUR EYE ETERNAL RESPECT.
THAT’S A DEBT THAT CANNOT BE
REPAID.
THANK THEM, TOO, IF YOU ALSO SEE
THEM.
BRIAN: ABSOLUTELY.
BRADY DUKE?
>> I’M PROUD OF MY SERVICE.
I KNOW MANY VETERANS ARE PROUD
OF THEIR SERVICE.
I WANT TO SAY TO THOSE WHO HAVE
SERVED BEFORE ME, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
AND THOSE WHO HAVE SERVED
AMONGST ME, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE PEOPLE THANKING
ME FOR MY SERVICE AND, YOU KNOW,
I THANK ANYONE WHO HAS SERVED IN
THIS MYRTLE HAS PLAYED A VITAL
ROLE IN PROTECTING OUR FREEDOM
AND HOLDING BACK THE ENEMY.
AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY SAY THANK YOU.
BRIAN: MORGAN, WHAT’S THE NAME
OF YOUR PAC.
YOU FORMED A PAC AND YOUR
MISSION TO WIN NEXT YEAR?
>> WELL, BEFORE I GET INTO THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT VETERANS DAY, TOO.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE HEARD EVERYBODY
ON THE SCREEN THANKING -- YOU
THANKED THE VETERANS AND THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE WALKING AROUND
THAT VERY UNASSUMING I WALK UP
TO THEM ALL THE TIME THANK YOU
LARRY AND RICK AND THANK YOU
MARCUS.
BUT I LEFT OF CENTER SAY THANK
YOU TO THE SPOUSES.
BECAUSE, WITHOUT THEM, WE
WOULDN’T BE WHO WE ARE TODAY AND
THEY MADE SUCH SACRIFICES SO
WHEN I SHARE MY EMOTIONS ABOUT
VETERANS DAY.
I ALWAYS THANK THE SPOUSES AND I
THINK THAT’S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
WE SHOULD NEVER FORGET THAT.
>> AND THE NAME OF YOUR PAC,
RYAN?
>> SEAL PAC.ORG.
AND IT HELPS WE HAVE SEVEN SEALS
NOW.
THREE GREEN BERETS, RANGERS, SO
WE’RE SUPPORTING OUR PATRIOTS UP
FRONT.